in this video I want to run through the
timeline of the full division story up
and to the point of the black tusk
launch the full invasion of the US
Capitol I've noted some confusion in
regards to the story so I'm going to use
this opportunity to round up the story
as sort of a recap piece but also to
show how the division one sit in New
York City crosses over with the division
to Washington DC
[Music]
[Music]
November 2015 Black Friday a man-made
virus later called the dollar flu was
released onto the unsuspecting American
public during one of retails busiest
days of the year based on the original
smallpox virus it was coated onto
banknotes by its creator dr. Gordon
Amherst and distributed in Abel's
department store where it quickly spread
from person to person through the
exchange of money while the virus was
still in its incubation period and
continued to quickly in fixed shoppers
and tourists across New York City before
the first symptoms of the virus could be
seen December first symptoms of the
dollar flu began to emerge medical
facilities are quickly overwhelmed by
the number of cases the federal
government's disease control division
and other federal authorities stepped in
and quickly declared a state of
emergency unfortunately it was too late
the virus had spread too fast
and the option of containment seemed
impossible the National Guard was called
in and the whole of New York City was
put on lockdown roads in and out of the
city are blocked off public transport is
suspended businesses closed and people
are ordered to stand their homes New
York City has become like a ghost town
December 6th President Lawrence Waller
orders a lockdown of New York City the
US military was called in to seal off
any means of exiting the city Sara
begins Mass vaccinations focusing on the
first responders and health workers
before moving on to the public via
clinics workspaces and large parking
lots
this created a feeling of relief in the
city stores begin to reopen and people
were allowed back onto the streets
under a curfew throughout the city Sara
set up field clinics and distributed
supplies and medications Sara also set
up a mass treatment facility for
advanced smallpox cases which was
located in a sealed-off section in the
middle of Manhattan
medical personnel started to round up
infected citizens and bussed them to the
treatment facility construction of a
reinforced perimeter wall also began
days later the feeling of relief turns
to horror as medical staff fund the
existing smallpox vaccine has no effect
on this new strain of the virus on top
of this the relaxed attitude towards
public activity and curfews allowed the
disease to spread further and faster
than before shortly after the first wave
of deaths sweep across the city December
11th the World Health Organization
officially declared the outbreak a
pandemic the president invoked martial
law nationwide in New York food and
supplies begin to run low meaning the
black market started popping up in large
numbers and smuggling activity increased
fear and Anarchy starts to spread and
looters readily break curfews and began
threatening local hospitals and
businesses many people try and leave the
city unfortunately with the government
troops enforcing the quarantine lines
escape was now impossible heavily
outnumbered security teams begin to
withdrawal from some of the more
dangerous neighborhoods due to the
increasing violence and mob activity
around this time the decision was made
for the police and military to join
together and form the joint task force
meanwhile the global pandemic had
reached Washington DC residents aware of
what was happening in New York panic and
mass civil energy spreads across the
city due to this public services break
down within 72 hours
December 15th in an attempt to control
the spread of the disease
authorities designated new containment
areas in Manhattan and makeshift
barriers were erected by local engineers
treatment facilities located in the
center of Manhattan had become more and
more dangerous mob activity was an
all-time high violent escape attempts
Wrigley occurred and barbaric activity
in the city was only getting worse as
the JTF continued to suffer heavy losses
they had no alternative but to leave
large sections of the city uncontrolled
in Washington DC the US Capitol Police
and metro police locked down the entire
District of Columbia and National Guard
units are summoned to provide extra
protection for federal workers and
government officials December 18th in
the face of the growing crisis President
Waller invoked the National Security
presidential directive 51 activating the
first wave of strategic homeland
division agents into New York City the
president along with his family and
senior staff were evacuated from the
White House two days later the sealed
off Manhattan treatment facility fell
due to the overwhelming stress and panic
from those being held within the area
became a death trap filled with infected
corpses fires and hostile Yanks from
here again Danu named the dark zone
within 24 hours the JTF of medical
personnel were forced to abandon the
area they fell back to the James Farley
post office and set up a new base of
operations for both Sara and the JTF
late December reports from the first
wave of division agents described
unimaginable levels of chaos though they
continued to fight through the growing
violence and an attempt to restore order
to the city but over the next few days
contact with the entire division team
was lost reports are now coming in of up
to 200,000 casualties due to the virus
and the growing violence within the city
and many more are missing New York City
is on the brink of collapse
on top of this a breakout from Rikers
Island has occurred thousands of violent
and district criminals have escaped and
are now running loose on the mainland
many of them band together to form a
powerful new gang called the Rikers and
began carving out large portions of the
city as the territory January 1st 2016
division agents from the District of
Columbia in Washington DC were activated
by the president food and gas shortages
combined with widespread power outages
has created citywide rioting and looting
high-level government officials were
relocated to secure sites around the
country just like in New York military
and police agencies in Washington DC are
combined into a single unit called the
Joint Task Force treatment facilities
are established by Sara inside the
Smithsonian castle and the National Mall
and on Roosevelt Island January 6th
after the disappearance of the first
wave the president activates the second
wave of division agents in New York City
after suffering heavy losses on the way
into the area the second wave begins
clearing the hostile presence with the
JTF
January seventh President Waller dies
from cardiac arrest rumors start stating
that he died from the dollar flu and
turned creating a new wave of panic vice
president Thomas Mendez has sworn as
president January 10th the Joint Task
Force promotes the head of the Maryland
National Guard colonel Anton Ridgeway
to JT a field commander with the new
rank of general Ridgway begins and
merciless crackdown on mole balance in
the capital late January the city's
infrastructure continues to fall even
with the National Guard camps being set
up across DC order is becoming
increasingly difficult to maintain as
game fighting spreads across the
northern neighborhoods early February
the situation continues to get worse in
Washington DC the broken chain of
command and the US military causes
troops to be thrown into crisis there
are decisions widespread deaths and the
uprisings of the hostile factions are
starting to get out of control
[Music]
February 14th the gang fighting in the
northern parts of DC stop due to several
of the major criminal gangs calling a
truce and forming a council this group
would be known as the hyenas and would
their new combined force and now able to
spread the violence faster and further
throughout the city late February
General ridgeway's increasingly lethal
measures in pursuit of re-establishing
control over the city eventually leads
to his arrest a court-martial and
imprisonment loyal members of his JTF
unit break him out and under ridgway's
leadership this new force who would now
be known as the true sons made it the
goal to establish territory and dominate
the populace
early much spring bring some ease to the
situation but in Washington DC the JTF
have collapsed and the gangs now have
nothing to stop them from taking
complete control of the city on top of
the survivors of the force quarantine on
Roosevelt Island that were originally
under Richards control have overthrown
the camp after being mistreated for too
long out for revenge on the JTF and the
general public that allowed it to happen
these survivors formed a new faction
calling themselves the outcasts a Sara
refugee camp established at George
Washington University begins to achieve
self sustainability and defense this cap
grows into a community settlement that
will be known as the campus in the east
general Ridgway and the true sons gained
control of the US Capitol building and
established the headquarters late March
civilians desperate to escape the gang
fighting in the northeast of DC start to
assemble in Ford's Theater led by former
division agent Podesta Sawyer after the
death of the cinnamons previous leader
the residents fortify the structure and
built a self-sufficient settlement
called the theater April 9th just three
months after being sworn in President
Mendez dies from an apparent suicide
but circumstances around his death
indicate that the Secret Service may be
compromised hidden away in an
undisclosed location with other members
of Congress Speaker of the House
Andrew Ellis is sworn in as the new
president
early May Air Force one is fired upon
whilst returning to Washington DC crash
landing near the Capitol president Ellis
survives but is captured by the heinous
the sh t network is mysteriously taken
down cut off from each other the
division agents follow through with
their operational guidelines which lead
them back to the nation's capital over
the following days agents arrive from
various parts across the US to find the
White House under siege by the various
hostile factions that are running the
city late May Washington DC has been
reduced to three remaining settlements
the castle the campus in the theater and
they are under constant threat by the
hostile factions the divisions main base
of operations the White House is still
under pressure to so agency forces are
spread thin across the city while
attempting to defend the few remaining
settlements and expanding the network of
safe areas early June the true sons
launch a chemical assault on the
settlement and the old Smithsonian
castle most residents die immediately
from the attack with the area now being
contaminated the settlement would become
a no-man's land
late June the division managed to rescue
president Ellis from the hyenas and a
new secret organization called the black
tusk is revealed to have been
responsible for the sh t network being
taken down July
division agents recovered prison Alice's
briefcase from the true sons of the
capital building with this the prison
was able to access the location of the
broad-spectrum antiviral the cure for
the dollar flu but as the city starts to
celebrate the series of small wounds
president Ellis disappears without a
trace at the exact moment that the black
tusk launched a full invasion into
Washington DC and now we're up to the
present game time where the division was
able to stop the antivirals from being
extracted from the Capitol and president
Ellis has discovered to be a traitor
with his location still unknown
hopefully that cleared a few things up
but there is still one thing that
doesn't quite make sense and this was
brought to my attention in the comments
section of one of my previous videos and
on my discord by the keen-eyed user
novena in New York the second wave of
division agents were activated and part
of their objective was to find out what
happened to the first wave over time it
was found that a number of them went
rogue under Aaron kinas leadership but
from a recording in DC we found that
this wasn't the case with all due
respect mr. president you can't hold up
in a situation like this half measures
aren't worth squat half measures my ass
those agents have full executive
authority and the most advanced tech in
our arsenal none of them matters if you
took them into the deep end without a
lifeline
Jesus Larry you've read history books
fine president wall was made aware of
the first wave going rogue long before
activating the second wave why wasn't
this passed on to the shd in New York
I've been speculating over this for a
long time and even my tinfoil hat
theories don't really make sense I
refuse to believe that there's simply an
overlooked detail in the continuation of
the division story so what do you think
happened here let me know in the
comments or on my diss code or even on
the Twitterverse i have all the links in
the description otherwise thank you very
much for watching and I'll catch you in
the next one Cheers